I lost my parents
that pain
made me who I am
I spent a lifetime trying to
write the wrongs of the past
as if fighting crime would bring my parents back
you actually did it
I can't imagine what you've been through
I love you monkey you lost
both parents in one day very
I went back in time to save my parents but
instead I completely broke the universe
if you went back and changed the past
this world must die to change the future
do you know what the symbol
stands for means hope right
I will help you if I thought
you want to get nuts let's get nuts
I have to undo what I did these
scars would have make us who we
are I'm about to go back and fix them
no that's your tragedy to find you
wow
no matter what we do we're not going
to be able to fix this no nobody dies
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my new Flash trailer video there's a whole bunch
of new footage in Easter eggs so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos also do
a movie ticket giveaway when we get a little bit
closer too this trailer just doubles down more on
Michael Keaton's Batman talks a little bit more
about his origin story and why he became Batman in
the first place about losing his parents and about
how the flash literally was able to go back and
save his parents whereas Batman was metaphorically
trying to save his parents like he knew that he
couldn't time travel but the flash actually did
time travel in Ben Affleck's Batman trying to
tell him some of the lessons of the comic book
Flashpoint like your pain makes you who you are
because that informs his own Batman character all
versions of Batman like they became Batman out of
their pain and that drives them to become better
people like he's trying to inspire The Flash but
then you have this other younger version of Barry
later in the trailer where he's screaming at our
version of Barry Allen from present day say no no
no nobody dies and it sounds like that informs
him becoming the dark version of the flashlight
they're just calling him dark Flash and he
has this Kryptonian looking crazy suit that
looks kind of like a version of reverse Flash's
suit from the new 52. he's sort of like a secret
villain in the movie from yet another different
timeline because we're talking about all these
converging timelines the idea of hyper time in the
DC Universe converging in this one place because
of the way they're fracturing time with the speed
force the movie is based on Flashpoint but it's
sort of a combination of the ideas of hyper time
different timelines like you talk about in the
Loki Series in the Marvel Universe In traditional
time travel that you see in the flashpoint story
in the comics every different comic book movie
has their own idea about how time travel actually
works but the trailer actually starts with
Michael Keaton Batman's character talking
about losing his parents why he became Batman in
the first place on the ruins of his Mansion but
remember most the movie is set about 10 years ago
in the past like this younger version of Barry is
about 10 years younger during the events or right
before the events of the Man of Steel movie when
zodge shows up but because we're talking about
hyper time here and converging timelines Michael
Keaton Batman's timeline has been supplanted on
this Earth combined with Barry's own timeline so
when he says I created a world with no metahumans
he's talking about these converging timelines and
it's the timeline for Michael Keaton Batman's
Earth where there weren't metahumans he touches
the picture frame of Thomas and Martha Wayne when
he was a child but just starting with all of his
suits here the one in the center is the one that
you see him actually wearing in the trailer it's
just meant to be his most advanced suit that he
has so far they didn't say how many years he's
been dormant like how many years since he's been
running around as Batman the way he looks it seems
like it's been more than a decade for the most
part they're all meant to be based on his same
design language from the 1989 Batman suit that
one is actually in the background on the right
here the one directly is the one that he wore
in Batman Returns is just slightly more armored
that was the whole joke of him using that suit in
the movie because Selena Kyle was able to use her
claws to penetrate his suit on the far left here
super deep cut this is meant to be a version of
his very first suit like his Batman year One suit
and the Batman symbol is also different from the
others if you couldn't tell all the other Batman
suits have the same symbol on it except for this
one this is meant to be the Adam West Batman
symbol from the 1966 TV series the pistols are
also meant to be grappling hooks not actual guns
according to the costume designer for the movie
he also said he designed the ears for this cowl
based on the Golden Age original Batman cowl from
the comics so it's like Michael Keaton's version
of Robert Pattinson's Batman year 2 suit a very
low-fi early prototype for what would become his
1989 Batman suit and other future suits speaking
of which for those of you that always wanted to
see Batman in the movies where the blue and gray
suit from the comics the one right behind this
is the blue and gray suit from the comics Ben
Affleck's Batman also wears his own version of
that in present day earlier in the movie it is
meant to be an updated version that's closer
to the design language of his normal bat Flex
suits but it's still very clearly the blue
and gray suit from the comics the next one on
the back right is another huge deep cut for the
Batman Returns movie it's the underwater Batman
suit that they sold as a toy but he never wore in
the actual movies it was just one of the many many
toys that they sold as merchandise speaking
of which the last one on the far right isn't
actually a desert suit even though you see the
goggles there it's actually another one based
on a toy they sold from the Batman Returns
movie called The Arctic armor bad suit and
it was just for cold environments or cold-based
villains like Mr Freeze raise your hand if you
spent all your money on all those Batman toys
when those movies came out back in the day
they do pretty much the same thing for every
Batman movie but it was just special back in
the day there were so many toys if you watch
the behind the scenes features they talk about
all the merchandising they did for those movies
they made so much money on the toys for those
first couple of Batman movies part of the reason
for them doing such weird deep Cuts though is to
tell you what happened to Michael Keaton's Batman
after the events of Batman Returns they're saying
that he went on to have more Adventures he used
these batsuits during them this is meant to be his
Batcave it seems like it's been upgraded since the
events of the 1989 Batman movie some of his gear
some of his technology has been upgraded like
he has newer versions of the bat suit he also
has a newer version of the Batwing the Batmobile
seems like it's the same one though you see the
Batwing slowly come down from its Hangar Bay
when he talks about spending a lifetime trying
to right the wrongs of the past the whole idea is
that he's been retired as Batman for a while and
it's both versions of Barry Allen that try to
convince him to get back in the suit and come
back into action and try and help them fix what
they've broken or what are barry Allen's broken
they finished the scene with Barry talking to him
in the bat cave where he says you actually did it
you traveled back in time and this is part of that
larger scene where he explains why he went back in
time like I don't want to live in a world where my
mom isn't alive during the custom DC logo too this
is actually meant to depict the speed force with
the flash traveling through it like that's why you
see that energy arcing through the reddishness
here we get a slightly new version of the scene
of him staring at his childhood home in the middle
of the night the woman saying I can't imagine what
you've been through actually sounds like Sasha
colay's Supergirl talking to him we get a longer
scene of him as a child with his mother and father
and his mother's death when she says you lost both
parents in one day she's actually talking about
the death of his mother but his father was hauled
to prison a big part of the movie or a plot point
is him helping his father get out of prison I
don't know if they've changed that a little bit
in the original verse of the movie the ending
was just a little bit different but I think that
part of the movie stuck like he's still trying to
get his father out of prison that's part of the
Flash's origin story that they've only hinted
at in the DC movie so far even in Zack Snyder's
Justice League the whole idea the reverse flash
is the person who actually killed his mother even
though the reverse flash himself isn't supposed
to be a big character in this movie unless they
radically changed his origin story I'm assuming
it was still reverse flash of the DC EU or now the
DCU and we'll just see him in a future movie or
they'll just tease him at some point during this
movie as far as I know they haven't cast an actor
for that role yet this is a similar scene of him
traveling through the speed force traveling back
in time when he's talking about going back to
save his mother and his father the way they cut
the footage is a little misleading I don't know
if this is meant to be the moment he arrives in
when he travels back in time like he stops in the
middle of the street and sees the Kryptonian ship
zod's ship destroying the Earth but this is meant
to be right when he arrives and the whole idea is
that the hyper time the combining timelines have
overwritten his own main timeline and now Superman
isn't there Aquaman isn't there as far as we know
Wonder Woman isn't there either and that's why he
has to sort of reassemble a version of the Justice
League with what he can find on this Earth like
he hears about a Kryptonian but it winds up being
Sasha clay Supergirl who came to Earth in her pod
not Henry Cavill Superman as far as I know zod's
whole storyline is fairly similar to what it was
in Man of Steel like he knows about the Kryptonian
signal so he's coming to Earth I don't know if the
whole codex storyline with the Codex being written
into Superman's DNA is holding with Supergirl too
that was really the reason why he came to planet
Earth because he was looking for the Codex he
didn't care so much about cal-el there's another
Easter egg for Henry Cavill Superman when she
asks him do you know what the symbol stands for it
stands for Hope and it is based on the design of
Henry cavill's Superman symbol in the background
you can see the younger version of Barry in
their homemade version of The Flash suit cobbled
together from an old Batman suit that they've just
repainted we get that classic Batman line you want
to get nuts let's get nuts you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
come on let's get nuts there's a new scene
of Batman dropping them into battle with the
kryptonians this scene is from earlier in the
movie when they're actually going to Kara's
prison and trying to find out which Kryptonian is
there thinking that it's going to be Henry Cavill
Superman nope it is not the whole idea is that
in Michael Keaton Batman's timeline the idea is
that Cara's pod fell to planet Earth the military
found it and then trapped her underground thinking
that she was a threat this just seems like a
scene of Barry looking at his childhood room
there's a longer version of the scene with Ben
Affleck's Batman talking to him explaining that
the scars that we have make us who we are like
the terrible things we go through help Forge us
into better people trying to convince the flash
that he should not go back in time not sure what
attack this happening in present day that they're
trying to stop but I think it's just meant to be
a regular attack in Gotham City Ben Affleck also
teased the gal gadot's Wonder Woman is going to be
part of this too and helps him during the battle
they have like a funny scene where she uses the
lasso of Truth to save him he winds up getting
really chatty and having this heart to heart with
her saying all these things that normally Batman
would not not say just because the lasso of Truth
is making him do it this might be a version of
the scene from the comic book Flashpoint in the
Justice League Flashpoint movie where flash is
trying to get his powers back and Kara takes him
into the sky to try to get struck by lightning
so that he can get them back during the original
version of Flashpoint in the flashpoint movie
The Flash has to shock himself a couple times
like he almost kills himself a couple times
trying to get his powers back not sure what
Supergirl is yelling at when she says what did
you do she might be yelling at Zod we get more
scenes from the battle with krytonian ships
crashing into each other it seems like she
almost winds up killing Zod and I think the idea
with her character is that because of what she's
been through because she's been locked up for
so long she has so much more pent-up anger than
Henry Cavill Superman did and as a result she's
a much more stabby version of the character like
imagine a much angrier version of Superman that
hasn't gone full Dark Superman like we saw like
evil Superman and Justice League Snyder cut she's
not quite that pissed off this is another scene
of them inside Carl's prison trying to rescue her
with Batman using his cape to block the bullets
this scene of The Flash running up the building
might have something to do with a Kryptonian
attack like it just seems like all of creation is
being swallowed up and destroyed really cool scene
of Batman flying through the air too in the middle
of whatever attack is happening in the regular
present day before the pass gets changed and like
I said this scene at the end of the trailer with
both berries talking to each other with the older
barrier like the regular Berry talking to the
younger version trying to convince him that they
can't save everyone seems like it's the turning
point for the younger Berry and they're inside
the speed force in younger Barry winds up going
off the rails turning into the dark version of
flash some of these scenes during the Kryptonian
fight like the Kryptonian jumping up on Batman's
ship and punching it seemed like it's right out of
the Man of Steel movie like they're paralleling a
lot of scenes from Man of Steel with a really cool
scene of Batman just jumping out of the cockpit
and using the cape like a glider to make it to
the ground then at the end when they transitioned
with the symbols you notice that they work in all
the character symbols like you have Michael Keaton
Batman symbol you have Ben Affleck Batman symbol
The Flash symbol and super girls symbol which
is the same symbol as Henry Cavill Superman
even though Wonder Woman is in the movie obviously
they don't put her symbol and I think because they
don't want to reveal her yet the very last scene
with Batman flying to Earth away from the Batwing
though is obviously meant to be a direct callback
to the scene from Batman 1989 with the Batwing
in front of the moon like they're literally doing
the same shot I'm sure there'll be lots of direct
scenes and callbacks to that 1989 Batman movie and
Batman Returns like they have the do you want to
get nuts line in the movie as well as a couple
other lines too like yes I'm Batman here you are
I'm Batman are you I'm Batman some of the other
cool cameos that we've learned about is that
there is supposed to be some speed force cameras
like really quick blink and you'll miss it cameos
for Nicholas Cage's version of Superman who's
supposed to be fighting a giant robot spider
and if you remember Tim Burton was supposed
to make the Nicholas Cage Superman movie and
during that movie during the original script he
was going to fight a giant robot spider so it's
sort of them doing an Easter egg for the Superman
movie that never was like it did happen just in
an alternate universe I believe that George
Clooney's Batman is supposed to have a cameo
somewhere in the movie too like blinking you miss
it kind of a funny moment but he's also meant to
be from a separate earth like they're saying that
all the older Batman's like Michael Keaton George
Clooney and Val Kilmer all came from different
Earths and supposedly there will be some Henry
Cavill Superman Cameo scenes in the movie but the
scenes are just taken from Justice League they're
not new footage that he filmed if you spotted
any other new Easter eggs or references in the
trailer that weren't in my previous trailer
videos just write them Below in the comments
I'll do more Flash videos soon we'll be getting
more footage really soon everyone click here for
my brand new Blue Beetle trailer video and click
here for all my other Flash trailer videos thank
you so much for watching everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!